se llama a sí mismo ingeniero rodolfo
hernández como si su profesión fuera
parte de su nombre y se autodefine como
un líder del mundo de la política
natural del departamento de santander al
noreste de colombia hernández creció en
el seno de una familia liberal y
siguiendo el consejo de su abuela
trabaje con los pobres y se hará rico
consiguió amasar una fortuna en el mundo
de la construcción como ingeniero civil
y empresario a pesar de que ya había
estado en política desde mucho antes su
carrera despegó en 2015 cuando fue
elegido alcalde de la capital de
santander o bucaramanga desde entonces
sus bases políticas son las mismas lucha
contra la corrupción la que llama buena
administración del dinero público y cero
impunidad con los criminales esta
situación no da para esperar si queremos
estar mejor la única solución es acabar
con la corrupción y también
convencimiento de llegar hasta los más
vulnerables con un discurso y políticas
fuertemente populistas
en un compromiso que los colombianos más
pobres
tengan un mejor vivir
muchos lo definen como el donald trump
colombiano que entró en el mundo de la
política como multimillonario y se
presentó como la opción anti
establishment aunque se han probado sus
nexos con políticos tradicionales y
otras polémicas como la filtración de
sus amenazas a un cliente de su
constructora por teléfono o un entramado
de corrupción el vita logic en el que se
le acusa de conceder un contrato público
supuestamente adeuda acusaciones que
siempre ha negado presentándose incluso
como puro
nosotros no ofrecemos nada
d
muy bien
a pesar de sus 77 años hernández logra
llegar hasta sus seguidores a través de
redes sociales conocido como el viejito
rey del edicto
[Música]
mientras el horno
desde donde pide a la población que se
suba a la rodolfo neta y vote por él